a lot of times when people are starting
out they don't think they're worth very
much and sometimes they're right but the
thing is is that you still need to
charge a certain amount so you can have
the excess resources to get better when
you have extra cash left over you can
reinvest in your product you can
actually research and you can test out
new things you can make prototypes you
can test out new divisions of service
you can attract higher level talent to
your business if you have no margin the
best people aren't going to work for you
why because they're going to go to the
real business owner who understands how
margin needs to work so they can attract
the best talent